Marmite just one of the items in a
hamper delivered to Michel Barnier by a
delegation of brexit eaters this week
very apt you might think when it comes
to brexit also included gin sparkling
wine marmalade and the complete works of
Shakespeare but was it enough to
persuade Michele to give the UK a good
trade deal join me now Stephen wolf MEP
who led the delegation I believe lovely
to see you thanks for coming in thank
you what did you make of Michele Barney
we get secondhand reports from those
involved in the negotiations you spent
some time face-to-face with man what's
your appraisal yeah it's not the first
time I've met him I've had conversations
with him in Strasbourg and I was one of
the first and only British MEP is to
have a delegation of over MEP is when he
was explaining what his strategy for the
negotiations were what you've got to
take about Michele Barnea is a very
strong-willed girl list French
politician he's of the mould where he
understands the politics as well as the
civil service but more importantly that
we have to understand his full strength
power idea and backing is behind the
eu-27 against the United Kingdom it's
his interest to make sure they are
protected not to help us I wonder what
Michele Barnea made of you in the
delegation you know the weird of brexit
tea as bearing gifts and all of that no
know how they could gin as much as the
next TV presenter but was that bottle of
Hendrix was that enough at persuading
Michele Barney to include financial
services in the trade deal no I don't
think it is at the moment to allow
financial services and a trade deal look
let's look at the context of why we gave
those various gifts some of them is to
show the link between like companies
like Unilever which is Anglo British to
say that we could continue trade and
Hendrix and the cheese's we have to show
the modernity of where we were going but
he will not allow us to have a trade
deal in my view that includes goods and
services and it will not allow one has
the free rein of the financial services
sector to be able to trade to where the
British public then when they voted on
leaving the European Union where they
sold something of a pot then because I
remember being told you know it'll be
fine we can continue the City of London
can continue to operate as it always has
well there was the conceit of London
will still be able to operate as it has
in terms of trade that's what we always
say just
we'll be able to buy goods and sell
goods and have the marketing elements
what the city needs to understand is
that where there are principles that
apply to you the United States some
something called equivalents that
equivalents will not be complete for the
British market now as I understand it
from our discussions with those in the
econ committee and what I come out with
Michele Barnea I think it's clear that
they're going to try and divide the city
of London to those of us like me who
think we can diverge and have our own
set of rules for those companies that
don't trade with Europe and allow us to
what we believe in if you're in Europe
trade on their rules and I think there's
an argument in the European Union that
that would be too competitive for
Britain therefore we must make sure all
British businesses comply with EU rules
I mean if you're right and if that turns
out to be the case and we essentially
hamstrung to an extent by the European
Union and in terms of that deal I mean
it's no deal better than that deal I
think that's one of the key points that
the delegation was taking to Michele
Barney oh you have in terms of Lord
Digby Jones somebody who understands
business completely you have in John
Long's with someone who understands the
businesses that a part of leave means
leave and the MEP MPs from the
Conservative Party of course with John
Mills two million supporters of the
labor movement behind his labor leave
and we were all saying to him if we
leave on WTO rules Europe will suffer
worse than us in what sense well we I
made a very quick point to him not only
was some of them high-end German
businesses and European businesses
suddenly hit by a tariff most favored
nation but as I'm being told traders are
informing me that the currency would
depreciate by 20% thus increasing
products in Germany by 20% to think of
that a BMW that might be 50 thousand
with a Land Rover now going to 60,000
what are you gonna buy the Land Rover or
the BMW Nigel Faraj raised a few
eyebrows this we can imagine yours
included when he really appeared to say
that a second referendum might not be a
bad idea put the debate to bed stop all
the whinging and whining of the room
owners well these mathematics are wrong
they're to start off with we're gonna be
the third referendum and this is not a
game of tic-tac-toe we're not here to
try and have the best of three the key
point that we should understand is that
Michele Barnea knows that he wants to
have brexit in March 2009
and the British people want to have
their referendum their vote complied
with and there should be no movement on
the idea of giving Ultra remain as the
view that they're in charge of this and
that they can reverse this and all he
did was give saccharin comfort and
support to the ideology he does have a
point that doesn't he when he said that
the remain campaigns such as it is it is
making all the running these days the
idea that you know the case for a clean
break from the European Union simply
hasn't been made well I think he's
absolutely right and we're aware of the
strength of the remain or arguments and
one of the points that we were doing
before Christmas by raising the petition
that was put online by a young man from
the north of England that's now got to
be debated in a few weeks time in
Parliament by my visit with this three
key people from the leave movement to
Michel Barnier the speeches that I'm
going outside a house of parliament this
afternoon and others around the country
there is a Lee fight back now on this
ideology that remain are going to win
you are of course no longer with with
you kit but but I have to ask you what
you make that the current for all
resounding surrounding the current you
kept leaders partner while he will eat
couldn't the last time I checked this
morning and should she be expelled from
the party should he be investigated as a
result of comments that she answered
I've left you keep a long time ago and
it's a matter for them all I will say is
that the Nigel has done this when he was
a leader we found that with Diane James
and myself is that national executive
and certain people within UK whether
those who are now no longer capable of
speaking for example in the Welsh
Assembly have allowed those views to
rise within UK but they were not there
whilst we had a balanced intelligent
debate within the party they need to
sort themselves out if they want to be a
radical party that can move at the
moment they're nowhere near it
briefly what is the point if you kept
these days well there should be a point
to represent those millions of people
here that are stuck in the middle of
between labour and conservative parties
who who ignore them and leave them
behind and don't listen to their views
and they really should have had that
mantle I don't think they've got it at
the moment and there's certainly no one
rising from the ranks capable of taking
it well we all have their delightful
prospect of another you kept leadership
election to the top and Stephen wolf
lovely to have you in the studio that I
present being with us taker thanks